Organic Grace is on the main street in Garboville and on the web at organicgrace.com
[music]
the
I consult with clients about a wide range of conditions and recommend herbal medicines and dietary advice and
like I said
every third Friday of the month we have a topic that we choose to open up and
Once again, I'm very pleased to have dr. Raymond Peake to share his wisdom and his expertise
during the show
From seven thirty to eight o'clock at the end of the show
Listeners are invited to call in with any questions either related or unrelated to this month's subject of longevity
So you're listening to ask your herb doctor on KMED Galbaville
91.1 FM and from 730 till the end of the show at 8 o'clock as I said you're invited to call in with any questions
The number here if you live in the area is nine two three three nine one one or if you live outside the area the toll
free number is 1 800 KM
UD rad rad
Now we can also be reached incidentally
Monday through Friday on
1888 WBM herb for consultations or further information
So once again, we're very pleased to have dr. Raymond Pete with us dr. Pete. Yes. Hi. Thanks so much for joining us again
I know that a lot of your background has been involved with reproductive physiology and aging and so
As always I would ask you just to introduce yourself and your professional and academic background for people perhaps who've never listened to you
Okay, um, I started getting interested in aging of I
guess in childhood, but through the 1950s when I would mention it to
people a
Few of the very old people like a biology professor who studied
around the turn of the century
had some interesting ideas about the actual cause of aging and
that
suggested possibilities for actually preventing it but
most people in the 1950s
Weren't at all interested in the idea of curing aging. It just was inconceivable that
Anything could be done about it. But
Finally when I decided to go to graduate school in biology
1968 to 72 at the University of Oregon
to do I
intended to study brain
biology, but it happened to
There were some good people working on reproductive aging. So I did my dissertation on
Female reproductive aging and
That helped to answer some questions that I've been accumulating for 20 years
but it
Really just opened up a lot of basic biological questions
the whole nature of what an organism is and how
It develops through time
Growing up from an egg to an adult
the whole process is
Something that
used to be explained as sort of
reading out
from a
pre-established blueprint in the genes
and
that
Led to the idea that there must be genes
causing aging and death and
Rethinking that whole
developmental scheme is necessary and
if you see
development as epigenetic or open to
interaction with environment then aging obviously is another
epigenetic
environmentally dependent process
Okay. Well what I'm most
most happy with and constantly amazed is your
interpretation of a lot of previously held scientific facts for one of the better word that
Both I was taught when I was doing my degree and the science that we had was the same
medical science that doctors get and still flawed with all of the same mistakes and
What I really appreciate is you bringing out?
some very
Some very different perspectives on it, which I think is very important and a very scientifically based perspectives and ones that are not actually hidden
I mean they're there in the articles and the abstracts of
Published medical journals, but it's very slow to reach the doctors. So in terms of tonight's show and
Going over longevity. I think it's a subject that most people would be pretty interested in how to extend their lifespan
And I know that there's lots of gene research and a billionaire
Investor who's trying to do 40,000
Sequences a year and he hopes to get up to a hundred thousand sequences a year. So hopefully trying to find the answer
behind aging and go through people's genomes and also their biomes to find out
what they're
Dealing with and see if there's any link between those people that have
degenerative disease and cancers and those people that perhaps don't but why it is that they all die and see if there's any kind of
Answers that can be found. I'm sure they probably will find some answers to given long enough. So getting on to longevity then
I wonder if it's wrong to believe that we can extend our lives beyond
120 in this current world and be both healthy and strong and I think what I wanted to ask you first was I read a recent
study in a fairly
popular publication about long life and health in general
Excuse me published by the University of Wisconsin. There's actually published in the online journal e life
they were mentioning a
Trial that was done with a strain of E. Coli and they subjected this E. Coli
bacteria to a normally lethal dose of radiation that would normally kill a person and they took
Whatever few surviving colonies of E. Coli that they were
Reproduce them and doubled the dose and then took the survivors from them and doubled the dose until they got
20 generations down the line a
colony of E. Coli that were able to withstand a thousand times the lethal radiation dose that would kill a human and
We're looking at the mechanisms behind this to see what these gene mutations had done to them to enable them to resist the effects
So they were talking about the ability to repair DNA as a primary objective in facilitating longevity
what do you what do you think about the
protection of DNA in our body as a method of
sustaining longer life
I think there is a parallel between what the bacteria are doing and what happens to
humans exposed to stresses like radiation, but
the single-celled organisms are
essentially different in how they respond to stress because
20 generations of
bacteria would be just a few days and so they
couldn't possibly be
evolving new
DNA sequences to make new
functional proteins in such a short time the radiation
Degrades protein so it it tends to simply knock out
functions
when it's damaging the DNA and the bacteria that died had their
DNA so damaged they lost
function and the ones that survived
simply didn't lose the function, but they
Their defense processes were activated and so what they were getting with each generation was
an intensification of the defense reactions that ordinary bacteria have and
Things like bacteria yeasts and
protozoa
When they're under stress they can either decide to reproduce faster
Live more intensely and and divide more quickly
if their genes are still working or they can
go in the direction of sort of dehydration and
for radiation
forming a spore and
eliminating a lot of water right makes the
DNA very resistant to radiation because water is part of the
hydroxyl
Radical is what destroys the DNA and so without any water
Tied to the DNA. It's very resistant. That's why spores can live for so long and in the desert or yeah
and so
If if humans tried to do that the cells under stress would either multiply
Very rapidly and that would be a cancer or or they would
Go into something worse than hibernation and in which they simply dried up and
were like a
suspended money's like
Existence. Okay, so it just doesn't work for humans on it. Yeah, the same idea is that
We have
ways of handling damaged genes or threats to the genes and
what people do or animals is to
kill the whole cell when
the
When the organism senses that the DNA has been damaged beyond the capacity to
Repair it
So it's happening very fast. The cells will turn over quickly, but
to not form a cancer they have to
Let the damaged ones
sort of a triage
beyond a certain
Degree of damage they have to let the cell die and the quicker it can die
the
More material is available for stimulating stem cells to replace it
so the
I think a major
factor in aging is that things interfere with that whole process of
either repairing or
letting the cells die quickly to be replaced and
in old age
the process of cell death is
retarded
Interestingly, yeah
Cells become old they can't decide
What to do and so they slow down the whole organism
Metabolically slows down and in that slowing down process
They have some
Undesirable products like
Lactic acid that cause problems for the whole organism and instead of just dying and getting it over with
So you're saying that the process of apoptosis or that cell program death is actually slowed down in normal human aging
Yeah
Okay, I think people are now
looking for
What what the factors are that retard that?
quick replacement quick apoptosis and
Activation of stem cells interesting. All right, we're getting getting on to energy
I know that you're very interested in
energy promoting substances and thyroid and progesterone
Aspirin etc being amongst some of those
definite energy promoting substances well
There's a compound called
NAD
NAD+ and
another form NADH
which is very important in terms of
intracellular
extracellular energy
conveyance and powering reactions, so
the article that was
using the E.coli forms and resisting
And providing a strain of E.coli was super resistant to radiation was also mentioning that
This compound NAD+ was another
target therapy and they'd actually produced a a form a patent obviously a
patented form of this product that they were trying to sell and
I think that's also part of this evening show is to try and highlight some of the
Some of the mistakes that we commonly are bombarded with in terms of being told it is the truth and will bring out a couple
of these and you'll specifically
identify the mistakes that the authors of the publication or the promoters of the product were
guilty of
perpetrating if you like but
NAD+ then as a compound how and how important do you see NAD+ and therefore this company's
new
product
To be taken as a supplement to raise NAD+ how important that would be in our biological systems
Our cells are
constantly in a process of oxidizing
and things like sugar the
electrons go to
the oxidizing NAD+ and
Reduce it so that it becomes NADH and
NADH can then pass those electrons on
eventually to oxygen so there's a streaming through
NAD+ and NADH to the mitochondria and oxygen and
That's
in the normal
metabolism you should have
three to five hundred times times as much NAD+ as
NADH
because it's in a rapidly oxidizing state and
Stresses that interfere with
Oxygen or that
subtract the
NAD+ and NADH
The lower the supply of the total NAD and NADH is the more easily a stress
Causes a
failure
Of the the balance so it shifts more easily
Through a very reduced NADH dominant
Okay, and so stress depletes NAD+
Well it depletes both of them one of the things that depletes both of them is
Damage to the DNA such as radiation
and in repairing the
DNA breaks
there are enzymes that
build up a chain of
repetitive bases
So it's a meaningless chain, but it
plugs up the hole basically in the DNA and to do that to to
repair the chain the
ADP is
attached
ADP comes from the supply of NAD
NADH and so when you get a nick in the DNA you have this huge amount of
NAD+ NADH available and you you draw it down to
Repair the damage if you draw it down in repairing too many
broken DNAs
then that
Interferes with the energy production of the cell okay, and
If you
Have ways to block those enzymes and stop the DNA repair then the cell
Can make the decision to die and right up wasting and right?
It becomes raw materials for the stem cells yeah
Is there anything that you know of that would more?
Preempt that destructive apoptotic phase rather than wasting energy trying to repair
Damage chromosome damage yeah, there are several drugs that will block that enzyme
It's it's initials are PARP the AARP and so PARP inhibiting
enzymes
can
save
cells from dying unnecessarily
It can
Put if you inhibit that process you can give the cell a chance to rest or you can
Inhibit it and let it go ahead and die
Interesting okay pop
Night now some amide it happens to be a very safe
Way to inhibit that that enzyme
At the same time is is the
precursor for making nad plus nad H
so you're
Plugging the drain and filling up the pool at the same time when you
Have a good source of niacin amide and we can normally make that from proteins the tryptophan
Converting it to the niacin
but if we're deficient in protein and
or have something blocking like a vitamin deficiency that blocks the conversion of
tryptophan to niacin
Then we can't keep the nad supply
Adequate would put this deficiency be pretty easily recognized. I mean it would be a typically known condition
The the chronic extreme state of was known as
Allegra
it occasionally turns up with a
rough skin condition when a person reaches a
great deficiency, but there are earlier signs such as mood
disturbances and
Various energy related and
Many many
variations on symptoms
Okay, let me just okay, so you're listening to ask your doctor on KMED Gabavel 91.1 FM from 730 till 8 o'clock the end
Of the show you're invited to call in with any questions either related or unrelated to this month's subject of longevity
Dr. Raymond Pete is joining us live
And so dr. Pete does carry on the subject of longevity
It an article also bought out the compounds called sir Tuins
sir one and sir three and
They were also posited you know nothing is a contradiction of that the article mentioned
But they're posited as another factor to improve longevity and that nad plus was a cofactor in their production
What was your opinion of calorie restriction as a way of?
Activating the sir Tuins, but not necessarily the surgeons are not necessarily positive are they they're more for
hibernation or yeah in calorie restriction
the organism has to do something to survive and so it starts shutting down turning off the genes and
the initials stand for
silent information
regulators
the
silent information yes, I are and in yeast
Starvation or stress will turn those on and and turn off genes and
in
Animal cells they do the same thing, but what how they got?
to be so
Interesting is that a group at Harvard?
was arguing that I
longevity in yeast
Corresponded to long life in humans, but in single-celled organisms what they were saying was
rapid and continued cell division
the equivalent would be cancer in a dry long life and from
from the
ability to
stimulate
rapid and prolonged cell division in yeast
They argued that
rest veritrol which is
related chemically very closely to
TES diethyl still best draw a simple
synthetic estrogen
Respiratory was a natural
still bean
type substance
found in grapes
it does have estrogenic activity and
Yeasts are especially sensitive the yeast produce
estradiol just like humans and
so so yeast is being
Given them basically an overdose of estrogen so it's more fertile
but in in humans that same sort of overdose isn't
desirable yeah
In the process of turning off genes
The when you do it in a human you are moving towards the
Spore like or hibernating state of not producing
proteins and
two of the
very important proteins that get turned off by the sirtuins
include
Clotho the the phosphate regulating
Protein that when it's turned off you get very rapid aging
degeneration of all of the tissues and
another
protein or enzyme a
p53 protein is
Tumor suppressor protein and so
So you don't want to just shut down and turn your anti-tumor proteins
Alright
Okay, but getting getting on to
This kind of the article again
We're saying that the age-related decrease in nad+ causes defects in energy and gene related functions to accumulate and do you think age?
Related mitochondria dysfunction can be reversed or merely protected for longer in the lifespan thereby gaining more time
down the road
Yeah
in several years ago the Harvard group
Someone in that group said that we shouldn't
supplement niacin
niacinamide
because
it
suppresses sirtuins
And they said the sirtuins are the long life proteins
niacinamide will accelerate aging but someone simply put human cells in the dish and gave them
supplement of niacinamide and
They lived 60% longer
So
there are various treatments that can do the same thing vitamin E for example and
adjusting amino acid balance and fats and so on but
simply
the
Adequate or enriched supply of niacinamide is enough to greatly
Extend the growth ability of human cells
Okay, well we do have a couple of callers here
We're coming already coming in so let's take them a little bit early, but let's take the first caller caller. You're on the air
Hi, hi, I'm where are you from caller? Oh? I'm calling from New Jersey, New Jersey, okay?
Hi
Once again, there's too many questions. I want to ask but I'll ask the question I originally called with I
understand the importance
you've talked about it others do talk about it of
Consuming high quality proteins if we want to you know maintain our systems and renew them
The it seems to be good for just about every body system, but there is one exception and that's the kidneys and
You said and I'm going to stress from your jet. I'm going to quote pardon me for your gelatin stress and longevity article
Since glycine is non-toxic if the kidneys are working
Since any amino acid will contribute to the production of ammonia
this kind of chemotherapy can be pleasant and
I mean, but I recommend the article because the article as a whole is is wonderful
I hope you don't mind me taking this little piece out
But you're the first person that I've that I've you know read who has actually said you know that
any amount of amino acid will stress the kidneys and
so I guess what I'm wondering is is there a simple and
Hopefully sort of more or less immediate way that we can judge that we are getting enough
amino acids
In a day to achieve nitrogen balance or you know everything that we sort of need to accomplish for our bodies
But not so much that it's stressing the kidneys or some happy medium perhaps using a reliable
urine dipstick
Test or is there anything like that?
normal functioning kidneys
aren't stressed by a high protein diet, but when something is impairing kidney function such as
hypothyroidism or
other sickness
then
with low kidney function and
a lot of bacteria
In your intestine breaking down amino acids you can get
Accumulated ammonia and that's where
RLV and NIH I think it was researcher
proposed
using ketone
keto acids
equivalent to the essential amino acids which will
absorb
the ammonia
Even when a person has no functioning kidney ability to secrete ammonia
so just by feeding keto acids
if they're the equivalent of the
Essential amino acids you create them in your body by absorbing the ammonia and then making your own protein and
that was where I got the
the idea that some foods
would contain
natural keto acid equivalent and
we did
Chromatography on potato juice and found that they are rich in the keto acids which
Will function as amino acids
Even though they contain no ammonia because they can absorb ammonia from your blood
So
The kidneys will not be as stressed
That was for use in people who were having essentially no kidney function and
it
Avicii's research showed that
these
ketones or keto acids
Are very helpful for failing kidneys
but
Ordinarily there are many other things you need to do when you have kidney disease
you want to correct the
all of the hormones that are involved in the regulating kidney physiology, especially
thyroid
progesterone estrogen cortisol
And some of the pituitary stress related hormones
And
I understand that of course, this is a process and
You know, I mean, it's not something that I can just you know, take a pill and everything's going to go come, right?
And and it would be very important again to keep eating the raw carrot daily. Am I correct? I
Didn't
Sorry, I mean I understand that it's this is a process and that it would be very important to continue to eat the raw carrot
Daily, oh my correct to keep the ammonia down. Yeah, that does help with the
bacterial
ammonia production
Okay, and how often do you think it would be wise to I mean my kidneys I'm not on dialysis
My kidneys are not failing to that degree
But they are sore upon if I you know, press lightly or medium pressure
I can feel them and certain practitioners have told me that my kidneys are not strong
So, I mean would you recommend if you know that that I well that someone do
potato
This you said you use a centripetal juicer. Am I right?
Yeah a few people who had
Ammonia coming out of their breast every time they ate
Just about any any food containing protein
just a couple of meals of potato juice and
They were they started assimilating proteins
But in Beatrice research, he put him on a chronic diet of a keto acid supplement
Thank you so much, thank you, thank you, I'm going to look into it further into that I appreciate it. Okay. Thanks for your call caller
Okay, we've got a steady stream of callers building up here. So let's take the next one and
Move through them one at a time. You're on the air caller
Hi, you're on the air, where are you from?
I'm Chris from in Colorado Springs and I have two questions for dr. Pete one's on topic. The other one's completely off topic
First though I wanted to say that
To you Andrew that I and a lot of the listeners do miss Sarah and hope she returned
But I just want to say you've been doing a great job doing the show by yourself. So keep up the good work. Okay
Dr. P in terms of longevity in reading your articles
I mean one gets the idea of the importance of the saturated fats and the avoidance of the answer unsaturated fats
however in terms of proper oxidative energy and the importance that
sugars like sucrose lactose play into that
How important is it to maybe keep the fats on the low side and focus more on the sugars?
or is there still a minimum of
Fat and saturated fat that's important in terms of longevity
um a certain small amount of fat helps to stimulate the intestine and
activate absorption of the oily vitamins vitamin K D a and e and
The
about 30 or 40 years ago, I was looking at the
association of various fats with the cancer spontaneous cancer incidence and
I saw that coconut oil had the lowest of the natural oils, but
someone found that
Hydrogenated coconut oil containing zero polyunsaturated or essential fatty acids had the lowest
incidence of spontaneous cancer of all essentially like a
completely fat-free diet and
so the fact that
the even two or three percent of polyunsaturated fats in butter and coconut oil the fact that that
accumulates because our muscles for example
quickly oxidize the saturated fats and
preferentially we store the
more water-soluble polyunsaturated fats and and so over time even eating a
moderate amount of butter and coconut oil
Our tissues will become increasingly
saturated with the polyunsaturated and the fat cells
which store a little droplets of
fat
They for their own energy
Prefer like the muscles they prefer to oxidize the safe saturated fats
so our fat
tissues with age become
more and more concentrated with a
relatively pure
polyunsaturated
store of fat and
under stress
Fat is released and especially the
Polyunsaturated which is a more accessible to the stress activation
so with age
stress becomes a
more harmful
because you've stored up more of the polyunsaturated fat so
since we can make all of the
Saturated fats
Palmitate
stearate and we can
desaturate
stearic acid to make oleic acid and our own series of polyunsaturates
I think it's best to
get as much
sugar and starch in your diet preferably
sugars from fruit and milk and
minimize the exposure to the unstable
N-6 and N-3 fatty acids
Okay, yeah that makes sense
It's more of trying to displace some of the fat with more of the good sugars like you mentioned orange juice and
And then the lactose and milk if you are going to get a little bit of fat probably focus on the saturated
But it sounds like sugars are probably more important
So you're probably more of not a really a proponent just because you like saturated fats
you're probably still not a proponent of a high fat diet and say because you're more of sugars and importance of keeping the metabolism high and
all that
If I could ask you just a really quick question, I know Andrew
We got other people on there so just the one that's off topic
And I'm just really curious about my girlfriend's been dealing with this now for
Quite a few months almost a year now, Dr. P
I was wondering if you had any ideas on what the cause is for
People that grind their teeth at night throughout the night without really even noticing
She has no idea she's doing it, but then she wakes up and you know
She has her jaw sore and the dentist told her that she's grinding down her teeth
And I was wondering if you know what the possible cause is and maybe any quick solutions
I mean obviously focusing on the thyroid in the long term, but just maybe something in the short term that might help
There are several publications
showing that high serotonin is probably
the major
thing in in tooth grinding and
Probably also in restless leg syndrome where the legs churn during the night
So to lower high serotonin what would be the what would be the most straightforward way of lowering serotonin in someone
Reducing intestinal inflammation is the quickest way
Low thyroid is probably a factor in high high serotonin, but
simply
avoiding
slowly digested foods like
resistant starches or
Undercooked vegetables salads are very bad for
Irritating the intestine and and producing so cascara would be pretty beneficial for improving bowel motility and
excretion
Yeah, and some of these so-called soluble fibers
even pectin for example fruit
Can greatly increase the production of serotonin and disturb the sleep?
Okay, good. All right. Well. We do have several more quarters on the air, so let's take the next one
Hi, you're on the air. Where are you from? Yes, my name is Graham. I'm from Los Angeles
I
My wife has chronic fatigue, and I'm wondering whether dr.
Pete has any insights or thoughts on how to deal with chronic fatigue and in particular mitochondrial dysfunction
Dr. Pete oh
Yeah, yeah
basically the same
stress syndrome low thyroid excess production of
lactic acid and
all of the
stress
mediators
The
Serotonin and histamine are usually high with prolactin
shows up
generally
very closely associated with chronic fatigue
And the prolactin rises generally with when your thyroid goes down and serotonin goes up
Okay
So what would be your
You know suggestion in terms of let's say just sort of a dietary approach then
Things that are quickly digested and
raw carrot is
contains anti-inflammatory
chemicals as well as some
antibiotics and
They suppress
Irritating bacteria as well as binding some of the toxins and so they have an anti-inflammatory
effect that can
Seriously adjust your hormones in a good direction just having a raw carrot every day
Doctor
My wife has been a keen listener of a lot of your programs, and she has been trying the raw carrot
She finds that very hard to digest
and
Basically consume
Good point
Doctor go ahead. Yeah, the point of eating the carrot is that they can't be digested
so they release some of the
antiseptic chemicals
but
help to stimulate the intestine and carry out material because
They they don't break down and produce
bacterial growth
The way other starchy vegetables do so you can think of the raw carrot material grated raw carrot as a kind of bottle brush
Effectively, I think within the the loom of the gun. Yeah, and if you shred them with a fine
Food processor so that they're almost like hair
Yeah, that's the most effective kind of fiber because you get a lot of surface right surface area
and irritant
Okay, and doctor one final question
Metabolic syndrome. I've been having trouble with that. What would you suggest from a dietary position there? What syndrome?
Metabolic syndrome I find it hard to remove
fat with this diet exercise or proper dietary
approaches to get the fat off my belly and
the
Polyunsaturated fats are probably what set up that
inability to
Oxidize sugar
efficiently and
it keeps the
free fatty acids in circulation and
free fatty acids
block your metabolism in general
so you can break the cycle in in various ways, but
probably a
active
form of thyroid containing
t3
Is the basic way to get the metabolism going so that you can oxidize?
glucose and
Turn off the free fatty acids any suggestions is one on there that I could consider
The important thing is to keep track of your
Metabolic rate how many calories you need?
How much water you're able to evaporate?
both high-rate people
Find that a lot of the water they they drink comes back as urine or
You should be able to evaporate a couple of quarts of water a day that
means that if you drink three quarts you get one quart of urine back per day and
other indicators of metabolic rate are
heart rate at rest and
temperature cycle
temperature should rise to
around
98.6 right after breakfast and stay there until close to sunset
Thank you doctor very much appreciate it. Okay. Thank you for your call caller. Okay, so the number if you live in the area is 93
who
three nine one one two and if you're outside the area that
800 numbers 1 800 KM ud rad so we've got dr. Raymond Pete
Sharing his wisdom here and the subject for this evening's longevity
Okay, so dr. Pete. I wanted to carry on asking you some more questions about the B vitamins. I know that
They're intrinsically involved in energy generation and its transfer
What what would you suggest as the a good strategy to ensure adequate levels of B vitamins?
um a
Good diet that includes liver once in a while
milk regularly and or cheese
eggs regularly
seafood or meat
fairly regularly
At least once a week for some kind of seafood is good
For the trace minerals that might not get in in some of the land foods given that it's water-soluble. Do you think?
How realistic do you think it is for people actually to be low in B vitamins B vitamins that may otherwise make a difference?
Because I know you've mentioned
B1 and B3 is being something that has been intrinsically important in people's memory
their retention of information and how quickly it can make a difference just by supplementing with it and if they're supplementing the
premium
Previous I presume that they were low in it and so taking a supplement raised the B by that B levels
they're one in the three and
corrected their
Their mental mental state I think
B vitamins act very quickly so you can usually see an effect
Sometimes it's like with vitamin B1 you can often feel an effect in the first hour
with vitamin B6 you generally feel an effect in the first day and
with vitamin B6 sometimes
10 milligrams is all it needs and
One dose will often take care of a problem that has lingered for a long time
and
It's it's good if you can
use a few doses of the supplements because
most of the supplements have impurities and
Excipients that aren't good in the long run right I know you're a proponent of very modest doses, too
So what would you because I know a lot of companies sell B vitamins in these 500 milligrams, or you know?
ridiculous amounts especially of B6 or
B3 what would you recommend?
If a person has diabetes or cancer or something and has very high lactic acid production
300 milligrams in
divided doses
can help to normalize sugar metabolism and and lactic acid but ordinarily
10 or 20 milligrams plenty. Is this B3 we're talking about now?
No, that was a vitamin B1 and B3
for
major problems including diabetes
probably arthritis a lot of
degenerative problems taking 50 or 100 milligrams several times a day of
niacinamide
can
control the symptoms reduce inflammation
Protect the nerves and
Accelerate glucose oxidation and so on and I should mention that
the
for some reason I think doctors liked
Nicotinic acid because it had such visible effects of making you turn red
but
people
generally don't like the feeling of flushing and it isn't good for your health because it it releases
serotonin histamine and
toxic prostaglandins, so it's actually causing damage when it flushes you and
In recent years
The market has been flooded with something they call no flush
Niacin, but if you look at the label
You'll see that it's
inositol
hexa
nicotinate
and that means that each molecule has six nicotinic acids and
It's a little slower to release
That's why it doesn't cause the sudden intense flushing, but it's the same
substance that's releasing
those
inflammatory toxic
Substances so it has to be either niacin amide
or the new
Niacin amide or nicotinamide
Riboside
Just a variation on niacin amide and it's a lot more expensive, but
If you have an allergic reaction to one you can try the other
All right, I very quickly want to just ask you to
remind listeners
The dose and you mentioned specifically for cancers even
B1 of two to three hundred milligrams in divided doses
Yeah, it's safe. Yeah, take as much as 300 milligrams and again. What would the benefits of that be?
lowering
lactic acid lowering lactic acid
stimulating the
oxidation of it and so you produce more carbon dioxide and
less
Lactic acid right that that shifts away from inflammation
Lactic acid is keeping the cancer
developing by creating inflammation and
Disturbing the pH balance good okay? Well, we do have a couple more callers, so um we should probably take this next caller and
See we say where it's takes us so caller. You're on the air
Hi, you're on the air and where you from
Hi, I'm from Laytonville. Hi. What's your question caller? I have two questions you mentioned the body temp
I've always had a low body temp like
97.4
That's normal or no
So what are some things like hot food ginger?
What are some things and well no not particularly because they just cause peripheral vasodilation
Which might give you a feeling of warmth, but might actually cool you down even but
Dr.. Pete when he mentions
Temperature and pulses as a measure or a good gauge for assessing thyroid function
That you should reach
98.6 during the daytime and preferably after breakfast in the morning
And you should stay at that kind of temperature pretty much all through the day until the evening
If you have consistently low body temperatures that do not seem to rise
After food and that would be fairly suggestive of metabolic deficiency in particularly that you'd benefit from using thyroid hormone
And a protein deficiency is a possible cause of low body temperature. I've seen
people who
couldn't respond to thyroid or other
metabolic activators and
It turned out they were eating something like 20 grams of protein a day for the requirement is
closer to 80
That makes sense. I have a blood type. I like high
cortisol
Active I need protein that makes them
My other question is what are your thoughts on chelation like the heavy metal cleanse?
Um good foods will
safely
activate the process of
Mobilizing heavy metals from the tissues and passing them out through the kidneys
coffee drinkers
Known to have a lower load of most of the heavy metals such as cadmium and lead
Do you think that foods a healthy diet would like naturally take care of
All of the heavy metals we accumulate
Yeah, one of the advantages of having orange juice milk in your diet
Constantly is that they provide materials that help to
inactivate the toxic effect of heavy metals while mobilizing them and
Washing them out through the kidneys
Yeah, thank you for your call dr. P. I've got to ask a personal question
I think maybe perhaps a lot of people might like to hear your your thoughts on this because they're always very different
And I'm always very very happy to hear what you say because it's always so illuminating
Ebola virus is becoming a very careful watch word right now
My son, I'm not being flippant at all, but what would you do? What are your thoughts and your suggestions on?
Ebola virus and how best to protect yourself from it if the effects of it are
basically like flu and many other
viral or or even bacterial infections that activate the
inflammatory processes and
Inactivate our immune defenses and if you look at the research
the
first thing that happens is the
inhibition of
interferon the antiviral
one of the defenses and
activation of nitric oxide production which
opens up blood vessels makes them leaky and
lowers energy production and so whether it's flu or Ebola or
Poisoning by by chemicals
The
method of
Defending yourself is pretty much the same to lower
Anything irritating that you're doing?
such as eating foods that are hard to digest and
Doing anything you can to lower
inflammation and nitric oxide production aspirin and aspirin and coffee and
niacinamide are all
defenses against
nitric oxide and I think nitric oxide is central to to all of those when they they get to the point of
causing
Degenerative bleeding
Processes what about interferon is anything that you would suggest that would be useful for raising your interferon or protecting or?
preventing the block blockage of it or the
No, I think that'll take care of itself if you just keep your energy up and hold the inflammatory
Things such as nitric oxide as low as you can okay, all right good. Well. I had to ask you
I thought you'd have some suggestions for it and
Thank you very much again. Dr.. Pete for joining us on the show and thank you callers for calling in
I know it's always very useful when people call in with lots of different questions
even if they're not related to the subject and
Just from where the callers come from the shows how wide an audience that you have dr.
Pete sir, thanks so much for your time. Okay. Thank you
Okay for those people who have listened to the show you want any more information outside of the show time
We can be reached on one eight eight eight WBM herb for consultations or further information
So dr. Raymond Pete's website. It's got a wealth of articles
Fully referenced they're not just made-up stories or unsubstantiated claims
they're actually very well written and very scientifically based and
science is there really to point the way forward and
Anybody who does want to hope wants to disbelieve the science perhaps would be a little bit
little bit rash because science does have a good place and a very important tool for
finding out the truth behind the questions that plague us and so
There's lots of lies out there and the internet unfortunately is one of the wealthiest
wealthiest places
But also has lots of answers too, so it's just sorting out the information and dr.
Pete's always got a very different perspective
So I'm very happy that he spends the time that he does joining us on the show so his website is
www.raypeat.com
Lots of articles on his website that you can look at
And again until the third Friday of next month. Have a good night
[Music]
(Instrumental Music)
Alright. Came out thanks Jessica Baker of Jade Dragon Acupuncture for her support of
Redwood Community Radio. Practicing and teaching Chinese Medicine, Herbalism and Aromatherapy.
Jessica is available for conferences, workshops and private consultations. Located at 607
F Street Arcata. Jade Dragon Acupuncture.